Boa noite, Eliseu. Tudo bem? Você tá me
ouvindo bem? Eu tô transmitindo pelo
própria ferramenta do YouTube que
geralmente eu uso streams. Tá
ótimo. O vídeo tá bom também,
tá? Eu vou começar aqui pra gente não
atrapalhar
mais ainda, né? Boa noite, Estela.
Ótimo, obrigado pelo
comentário.
O Stream Art deu um bug aqui, deu um
pau, coisa que eu nunca vi antes.
Bem, mas vamos lá, né? Tô usando a
própria ferramenta aqui do YouTube,
só que eu acho que eu não vou conseguir
compartilhar a tela como eu geralmente
faço com vocês, tá? Boa noite,
Tamiquinha. Boa noite, Estela Mares. Boa
noite, Eliseu. Bem, pessoal, vamos
começar respondendo as dúvidas de vocês
e depois a gente passa pro discussão de
artigos, né?
Então, eu separei um material bacana
aqui para discutir com vocês, né?
Vocês já pararam para pensar como que a
quantidade de sono pode influenciar o
que nós comemos?
Você
já leram algum artigo ou já ouviram
falar de alguma notícia
sobre a correlação entre a quantidade de
sono e os alimentos que a gente prefere
comer? Se você já ouviu falar, por
favor, mande uma mensagem aqui. Nós
vamos explorar hoje uma pesquisa
fascinante que revela como dormir menos
pode nos fazer preferir alimentos mais
doces.
Então, preparem-se para descobrir como é
que o sono e o sabor tem correlação.
Estão mais conectados como do que nós
imaginamos.
Pessoal, só antes de eu continuar aqui,
só quero avisar que o post que eu
coloquei lá na área fechada do YouTube
com link original,
eu não consegui editar e eu não tô
conseguindo apagar também aqui.
Pelo menos eu não descobri aqui como é
que apaga.
Então, o link anterior não tá válido,
depois eu vou até apagar essa live, tá?
Então, você já notou que depois de uma
noite mal dormida, aquela vontade de
comer algo doce aumenta? Isso não é só
impressão sua. Tem estudos recentes que
mostram que a falta de sono pode
realmente aumentar a nossa preferência
por sabores doces.
Em uma revisão sistemática de vários
estudos, foi descoberto que dormir menos
de 6 horas por noite, menos de 6 horas
por noite, estaria associado a um
aumento na preferência pelo sabor doce,
mas não afeta outros sabores, como
salgado, azedo, amargo ou mami.
Boa noite, Fernando Castelane ou
Casteliane, né, melhor falando.
Mas como então que os cientistas
chegaram a essa conclusão? Eles
analisaram três estudos, incluindo sete
ensaios clínicos randomizados e seis
estudos observacionais,
envolvendo adultos de várias idades e
índices de massa corporal. Então, a
maioria das pesquisas foi conduzida nos
Estados Unidos, mas também países como
Brasil, Turquia, Espanha, Suécia e
Japão. Então, os participantes que
dormiam menos foram comparados com
aqueles que tinham um sono habitual de 7
a 9 horas.
Então, por que que isso importa?
Nós sabemos que o sono ele é essencial
paraa nossa saúde, assim como a nutrição
e exercício. E a privação de sono pode
afetar humor, cognição e até mesmo
aumentar o risco de doenças crônicas e
aumentar o risco até de ganhar peso.
Além disso, tumipouco tá associado à
desegulação de hormônios como os
hormônios do apetite, que a grelina e a
leptina, aumentando a fome e a ingestão
calórica. Então, compreender como o sono
afeta nossas preferências alimentares
pode ser a chave para melhorar na saúde
geral.
Então, é descoberto que a falta de sono
não só aumenta a fome, mas também pode
alterar a forma como nós percebemos os
sabores. Então, pessoas com privação de
sono tendem a consumir mais açúcares
adicionados e t maior desejo por
alimentos doces. Além disso, o sono
insuficiente pode aumentar a sensação de
prazer ao comer, levando-nos a buscar
alimentos mais palatáveis. Isso ocorre
porque o sono influencia sistemas de
recompensa no cérebro, possivelmente
levando a um ciclo de sono ruim e
escolhas alimentares pouco saudáveis.
Então essa preferência aumentada por
doces pode explicar em parte, porque
pessoas que dormem pouco tem maior risco
de obesidade. Então o gosto é um fator
crucial na escolha alimentar e uma maior
preferência por doces pode levar ao
consumo excessivo de calorias. Embora
ainda seja necessário mais pesquisas
para entender completamente esses
mecanismos,
fica claro que fica claro que melhorar a
qualidade do sono pode ser uma
estratégia eficaz para promover hábitos
alimentares mais saudáveis e combater a
obesidade.
Então pessoal, mais uma razão para
dormir direito,
mais uma razão para dormir bem, mais de
6 horas por noite
vai diminuir a compulsão por doce. Da
próxima vez que você pensar em cortar
algumas horas de sono, lembre-se de que
isso pode influenciar não só o seu nível
de energia, mas também as suas escolhas
alimentares, fazendo você ter compulsão
por doce. Então é muito importante
priorizar um bom descanso,
que é um dos quatro pilares principais
da saúde. Beleza? Bem, vou responder as
dúvidas agora. Eu acabei falando esse
artigo. Eu tenho mais dois artigos para
discutir com vocês aqui, mas vamos às
perguntas, tá? Eu não vou conseguir
dividir minha tela.
Vocês
vão, quer dizer, na verdade, eu não sei
se eu consigo dividir a tela aqui usando
essa ferramenta nativa do YouTube que eu
nunca usei pelo computador. Eu vou ver
se eu consigo divulgar aqui. Divulgar
não, dividir. Abriu outra janela.
Configurações. Feedback.
Eu acho que não, viu? Eu não vou tentar
não, tá? porque já teve essa confusão
hoje.
Bem, vamos lá.
Ah, não, eu já achei aqui onde é que eu
compartilhei a tela. Pronto.
Pronto, consegui compartilhar agora
aqui.
Mas eu vou ter que aumentar o tamanho,
né?
Tá dando para ler aí, pessoal, a tela?
Vou esperar o feedback de vocês aí.
Deixa eu ver aqui.
Dá para ler? Sim. Ok, Eliseu. Obrigado.
Primeira pergunta do Fernando. Qual que
é a fonte de consulta que eu posso
procurar para obter as recomendações
da ingestão de área de vitaminas e
minerais recomendadas pela
ortomolecular? Li um livro que os
valores
são 10 a 20 vezes maiores do que o
recomendados. Eu teve uma pergunta bem
parecida com essa. Em outra live eu
respondi que tem vários livros aí que
você pode comprar. compra os livros de
ortomolecular do Artur Lemos. O Artur
Lemos já publicou mais de 10 livros de
ortomolecular.
Qualquer livro de orto molecular que foi
publicado por um médico brasileiro vai
ser de bom tamanho, tá? E eu mostrei uma
live aqui, o Gabe, né, o Alan Gabe, o
livro Nutritional Medicine. Esse livro é
muito completo, mas tá em inglês, tá? E
é um livro caro,
então não sei se vocês vão querer
comprar isso, mas compra um livro do
Artur Lemos, tá?
Tem vários livros do Atom Lemos aí que
você pode tá
conferindo, dá uma pesquisada no site do
próprio médico.
Então, vou fazer algumas observações
aqui. As recomendações de digestões
diárias de vitaminas e minerais pela
ortomolecular geralmente realmente é
superior, mas vai variar de vitamina
para vitamina, de pessoa para pessoa.
Só que tem que tomar muito cuidado com
isso. Geralmente você tem que fazer isso
com o acompanhamento de um médico,
entenda o que tá fazendo.
Tem um site aqui que eu descobri agora,
chama-se Passei Direto, tá? Deve ser a
coisa para vestibular, que tem também
uns textos mais simples sobre iotomo
molecular. OK?
Vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui. É do
Thago. Em um vídeo no Instagram, um
médico comentou que está aumentando os
casos de pessoas com pólipos no ouvido e
outras neoplasias por conta de AirPods,
fones, Bluetooth.
O senhor tem algum conselho, aliás, tem
algum conhecimento sobre isso? As
empresas dizem que a radiação emitida
por esses aparelhos
não causam dano celular.
Porém, não há estudos a longo prazo
feitos ainda. Qual sua opinião e
recomendação com relação ao uso desses
dispositivos? É muito polêmico esse
assunto. Existe várias opiniões
diferentes sobre isso.
Dependendo de quem você checa, quem você
verifica, vai falar que que pode fazer
mal ou não fazer mal. Eu evitaria uso
prolongado desses aparelhos o máximo que
você puder. Se você puder usar sem fio,
aliás, com fio, o máximo que você puder,
melhor ainda. Na verdade, eu uso sem fio
em um único ambiente, tá? Só usa o fone
sem fio na academia, porque eu acho que
até complicado você usar aqueles fones
com fio na esteira da academia, porque
corre o risco aí de ter acidente.
Então eu uso no máximo meia hora na
esteira quando eu faço esteira na
academia. Então em outros ambientes eu
não recomendo você utilizar o sem fio,
tá? Use o o mínimo possível.
Oficialmente eles vão dizer o seguinte:
qualquer um desses fones Bluetooth, eles
emitem radiação não ionizante, que são
ondas de rádio especiais, né? No
protocolo Bluetooth,
nós sabemos que a radiação não ionizante
é diferente da radiação ionizante, como
raio X ou radiação nuclear, que é muito
mais potente, muito mais problemático.
As empresas sempre dizem que a radiação
que os equipamentos emitem que está
dentro dos limites de segurança, mas
óbvio que eles vão falar isso, né?
Porém, é verdade, como você mesmo
comentou, que não existem ainda estudos
a longo prazo que comprovem de forma
definitiva que esses equipamentos são
seguros anos e anos de uso, OK?
Então, use esses fones o mínimo
possível, mantenha o dispositivo que
está transmitindo o sinal mais próximo
também, porque se você deixar longe, o
sinal Bluetooth vai ter que ser
ampliado, né? Então, mantenha próximo
porque vai ter menos radiação dessa
forma.
E mantém uma dieta rica em antioxidantes
e nutrientes, né? Uma dieta rica em
fito, né? Nutrientes, plantas coloridas
que vão ter antioxidantes
e minerais que vão ajudar a proteger
suas células.
Então, cautela nunca é demais.
Qual a sua opinião em relação ao uso
controlado de nandrolona idosa com
sarcopenia
e osteoporose, levando em consideração
que os exames de sangue estão normais?
Thago, eu uso bastante, quer dizer,
bastante modo de falar, né? Eu tenho
aqui várias pacientes idosas
com sacopenia que eu já usei ferramenta
na androlona. Nunca me arrependi porque
eu usei por pouco tempo
e usei com parcimônia. Então, na
androlona usado com responsabilidade
numa mulher idosa,
funciona muito bem para osteoporose e
para sacopenia. Nunca me arrependi, tá?
Porque ela pode ganhar 4 ou 5 kg de peso
muito rápido usando androlona em poucas
semanas, tá? E esse é o uso original
desses anabolizantes. Eh, tudo que vocês
conhecem sobre anabolizantes, falando
mal de anabolizante,
é no contexto de uso recreativo,
que é o garotinho marombeiro usando para
ficar grandão, certo? Mas o uso original
dos anabonizantes é para
essa situação de pessoas que estão com
síndromes consuptivas, geralmente
pessoas que estão internadas em UTI e
que estão perdendo muita massa muscular,
estão caquéticas e também para pessoas
que tm osteoporose e sarcopenia. Então,
nesse contexto de pessoas de idade,
mulheres ou homens,
sacopenia chuporose, funciona muito bem
utilizar anandrolona. Nunca tive
problema. Tem que ficar atento só com
alguns detalhes, tá? Porque realmente o
HDL colesterol cai.
Pode acontecer uma dislipidemia,
pode acontecer um estresse no fígado
e pode ter um pouquinho de aumento, né,
na resistência à insulina.
Então tem que ficar atento esses efeitos
colaterais. Mas o médico vai est
observando isso. Isso quando é poucas
semanas de uso,
não é uma coisa que geralmente é
significativa. Obviamente você não vai
usar anabolizante em pessoas comência
renal importante, nem com essência
hepática importante. Você vai utilizar
em pessoas que têm eh uma saúde geral
razoável, né?
É muito importante que essa pessoa
também faça musculação, qualquer outro
exercício de força. É muito importante
que utilize uma dieta rica em proteínas,
que utilize cálcio, que utilize vitamina
D. Então não é só dar o anolizante e
usar também os outros minerais,
magnésio, zinco, cobre,
boro, silício, tudo isso vai ajudar no
osso, né? Vitamina A, D também vai
ajudar.
Então é uma abordagem holística, né? Não
é uma abordagem
só com anabolizante.
Fernando Cediani show o Nutritional
Medicine. Eu consegui o PDF e
disponibilizei no grupo.
Ah, sim. Você comprou, você tá falando
de um livro, né? Beleza.
Próxima pergunta do Eliseu. Deixa eu ver
se tá aparecendo na tela.
Tá aqui,
tá aqui.
Me de só um instante
aqui.
Então, pergunta:
"Recebi a informação que tatuagens
provocam doenças oculares, inflação,
inflamação intraocular, inflamação na
retina e coroide, uma condição rara
conhecida como uvite secundária a
tatuagem. Os sintomas podem surgir logo
no primeiro ano após a realização da da
tatuagem e inclui dor ocular, vemidão e
baixa visual. É verdade, é verdade,
Eliseu. Mas eu acho que você fez uma
confusão,
porque essas informações das
complicações oculares em relação à
tatuagem no olho, tá? Não sei se a
pergunta que você tá fazendo é essa. Eu
acho que não. Eu acho que você tava
perguntando sobre tatuagens em geral e
essas informações que você leu é
relativo à tatuagem feito na esclera.
OK? Não é a tatuagem feita na pele, não.
Então, mas tem que ser muito doido para
fazer tatuagem no olho, né? Mas tem
gente que faz, né?
Então, a tatuagem feita no olho provoca
inflamação intraocular,
inflamação na retina e na coroide,
uveite, né, que é uma inflamação na no
compartimento principal do olho, que é
úvia.
Então essa tatuagem maluca aí, a
tatuagem ocular, é uma injeção de tinta
diretamente na esclerocórnea. Tem que
ser muito louco para fazer isso, né?
E isso pode causar danos aos tecidos
oculares. São altamente arriscados esses
procedimentos,
porque as tintas não foram validadas
para uso no olho. Tem químicos tóxicos,
né, que nós sabemos tem metal pesado
nessas tintas
e podem acontecer esse sintomas todos
aí, dor ocular, vermelidão,
sensibilidade à luz, baixa visual, perda
parcial total da visão
e essa uveite, né, que é a inflamação da
úvia, a camada pigmentada do olho que
inclui a íris, a coroide, o corpo
ciliar,
que é a parte principal do olho aí. fora
retina pode ser uma das complicações
mais graves e pode surgir logo no
primeiro ano após a tatuagem. Então
também já foram descritos inflamação
ocular, catarata e glaucoma por conta
dessa tatuagem, tá? Doença do olho seco
também.
Eu acho que você mirou no passarinho e
acertou na galinha. Acho que foi isso.
Beleza, Eliseu? Então, o que você leu,
tudo que você leu aí
é aplicado a tatuagem ocular, não a
tatuagem na pele.
Pode tomar lugol e vitamina C ao mesmo
tempo.
Não vejo nenhum problema nisso não,
tá?
Não vejo nenhum problema nisso não.
Por que que você tá perguntando e você
já leu alguma coisa dizendo que não
podia?
Você tá ao vivo aí acompanhando?
Deixa eu ver quem fez a pergunta.
É Maria Helena. Eu acho que ela não tá
ao vivo não. Você tá aí, Maria Helena?
Será que você tá querendo dizer ao mesmo
tempo no sentido de tomar
eh na mesma solução? Seria isso? Porque
o logol você sabe que é uma solução
totalmente concentrada em iodo
e a vitamina C é um antioxidante, certo?
E a vitamina C na mesma solução do iodo,
pode ser que ela neutralize o iodo
livre.
Então, se você tá falando de juntar os
dois no mesmo copo, digamos assim, não,
não faça isso, tá? Porque pode a
vitamina, você pode neutralizar o iodo.
Próxima pergunta da Maria Helena também.
Cadê? Aqui tem muita defesa pelos
investidores,
mas é verdade que relógio no pulso com
bateria de lítium prejudica as nossas
células? Boa pergunta.
A gente tem que entender primeiro que as
baterias de lítio tem metais que
poderiam ter impacto a saúde se você
tiver um contato direto com ele. Então,
se for um relógio vagabundo, por
exemplo, isso
pode denotar que esse lítio pode entrar
em contato com a tua pele.
Aí o fabricante vai dizer que os
relógios modernos são projetados para
minimizar
qualquer risco de exposição de
toxicidade, né? Então, se for um bom
fabricante, isso não vai acontecer. Em
relação a campos eletromagnéticos, no
momento a gente tá no campo da suspeita.
Vai ter gente que vai defender com unhas
e dentes. A mesma situação lá do fone
Bluetooth que eu falei.
Vai ter estudo falando que o campo
eletromagnético desses relógios não é
intenso suficiente para causar problema.
Vai ter gente que vai dizer que não, que
vai causar problema, então é complicado,
tá? E vai ter estudos tanto para um lado
quanto pro outro.
Inclusive,
uma vez eu fui lá na clínica do Vent
fazer uma avaliação com ele e eu tava
com Apple Watch no pulso e aí ele fez lá
um, ele tem uma microscopista lá na
clínica dele, né? E eu fiz aquela exame
de microscopia de campo escuro e tirei
uma gotinha do sangue e a microscopista
avaliou. Tava dando aquela situação do
rollon, né, que as emácias estavam
empilhadas em moeda. Aí eu tirei o o
relógio de pulso, o Apple Watch, tomei
água, mais água e refiz e a agregação
deácias, né, o rollon lá.
Eh, não era rolão, é rolou, fenômeno
rolou, né, que em francês, eh, tinha
sumido. Ou seja, eu não sei se foi a
hidratação que resolveu isso ou se foi a
retirada do relógio, mas eu fiquei meio
cismado com isso e desde então eu tenho
utilizado bem menos esse Apple Watch.
Inclusive, ele tá até aqui numa gaveta
aqui meio parado. Tem vários dias que eu
não coloco ele.
Temos mais perguntas? Não, deixa eu ver
se tem ao vivo.
Ah, tá, miquinha, tá. É porque você tem
esse seu nick aí que eu não associei o
seu nome.
Você ouviu num grupo sobre iodo e
vitamina C, mas você ouviu no contexto
de de juntar os dois produtos, digamos
assim, no mesmo copo ou tomado juntos ou
você ouviu no contexto de, tipo, mesmo
tomando o iodo de manhã e a vitamina C à
tarde, daria problema?
Vou aguardar você me responder, tá?
Enquanto isso, eu vou discutir o segundo
artigo do dia. Ah, ela já respondeu
aqui. Contexto de tomar os dois no café
da manhã. Então você se você tomar eles
em momentos separados, assim, que seja
um intervalo de meia hora, não vejo
problema não, tá? Na verdade, vocês já
sabem, eu não sou grande fã do LOL, não.
Eu não usaria LOL mais, tá? Se vocês
puderem, usem o Yodo Kelp, tá? É mais
seguro.
Bem, vamos partir pro próximo artigo.
Saiu aí um estudo sobre a taurina.
Interessante.
Eu não sei se vocês assistiram meu vídeo
sobre taurina que eu publiquei anos
atrás.
falando dos benefícios, tá?
Então, esse estudo ele confirmou os
achados
e sobre a parte de saúde cardiovascular.
Então, o que que foi exatamente
estudado? Os pesquisadores estavam
interessados em entender o efeito da
suplementação da taurina em relação a
parâmetros cardiovasculares, pressão
arterial, entre outras coisas.
Então eles verificaram a frequência
cardíaca, a pressão arterial sistólica e
diastólica, a fração de ejeção do
ventrículo esquerdo, que é um parâmetro
principal aí do ecocardiograma, que é o
tanto que o ventrículo esquerdo consegue
jogar para fora do sangue que entra lá
dentro dele.
e a classe de insuficiência cardíaca
que é avaliada usando a classificação
funcional da New York Heart Association.
Quem participou do estudo foram 808
participantes, idades entre 89 anos. foi
uma faixa bem larga de idade, um grupo
bem diverso
e eles desde pessoas sem problemas de
saúde aparentes até indivíduos com
problemas cardiovasculares, defeitos de
válvulas cardíacas, insuficiência
cardíaca, miocardiopatia dilatada, aqui
é o coração inchado, né, dilatado,
pressão alta e diabetes tipo dois. Então
foi um espectro de várias doenças, um
espectro amplo,
né, que então vendo que a taurina pode
ser benéfica para vários grupos aí.
Então é uma metaanálise, tem um estudo
bem realizado porque foi juntado aí 20
estudos diferentes, 20 ensaios clínicos
randomizados. Então isso dá um peso para
esse estudo porque ele é a junção de
outros 20 estudos
que foram analisados com a mesma régua
estatística, né? Então, estudos que
foram conduzidos em vários países, né?
Rússia, Irã, Japão, Canadá, Irlanda,
Áustria, Dinamarca, China e Egito. A
dose de taurina varou de 500 mg a 6 g
por dia. A duração das intervenções foi
de 5 dias a 12 meses. Então você viu que
a variedade de doses foi bem abrangente,
né? 12 vezes, né? de diferença de 500 mg
para 6 g por dia.
E também os estudos foram analisando a
taurina, tanto a taurina tanto a curto
quanto a longo prazo.
Então, comparado ao place, que é pílula
de farinha, a suplementação com taurina
reduziu a frequência cardíaca em cerca
de quatro batidas por minuto. Além
disso, houve uma diminuição na pressão
arterial sistólica em 4 mmúrio, na
diastólica em 1,4 mm de mercúrio. Então,
teve um impacto relativamente baixo aí,
né, isoladamente.
E a classe de cardíaca também melhorou.
Então, os as pessoas que tinham
inspência cardíaca tomaram taurina,
tiveram melhor da função cardíaca e a
fração de ejeção do ventrículo esquerdo
aumentou em 5%.
E a certeza das evidências foi alta para
todos esses resultados. Então a taurina
sozinho já tem algum resultado. Eu nunca
usaria só taurina para pessoas com
doenças cardíacas, né? Eu usaria
taurina, carnetina, derribose, creatina
e também usaria com enzema Q10. Em
alguns casos eu colocaria também
a a nicotinamida ribosí, né, o niagen.
Então a conclusão é que a taurina pode
ter um impacto positivo significativo na
saúde do coração, melhorando vários
indicadores importantes. Então vale a
pena você colocar a taurina no seu
esquema. Se você tiver problema
cardíaco, se você tiver problema também
de memória ou de concentração, taurina
também tem uma ação eh perdão, cerebral
boa e a taurina também é top para detox.
Então, taurina é um um dos melhores
suplementos que a gente tem disponível
aí no mercado.
Eu tenho mais uma pergunta aqui da Maria
Helena Tamiquinha. É verdade que
estradiol
é melhor absorvido à noite? Não, não é
verdade isso não. Eh, o estradiol melhor
horário para você usar de manhã, mas não
tem nada a ver com absorção, tem a ver
com
a questão de seu horário mais apropriado
para você ter o pico do stride allol,
tá?
Acho que cabe mais um artigo, né, que
hoje teve pouca pergunta.
Bem, o próximo artigo
é sobre exercício de força em idosos
com mais de 70 anos.
Então, já falo aqui para vocês há muito
tempo que a musculação é fundamental
paraa saúde tanto muscular e óssea
quanto cerebral. E teve um estudo que
analisou exatamente o efeito da
musculação em idosos, o treinamento de
resistência, né, que é o termo mais
técnico. E o interessante nesse estudo é
que esse treinamento de resistência foi
pesado. O pessoal aí meteu bronca nos
idosos, né? Meteu bronca nos velhinhos.
Então, foi um ano de avaliação, um ano
de treino, eles verificaram que houve
realmente benefícios muito interessantes
que nós vamos discutir aqui.
Então, estudo ensaio clínico randomizado
avaliou o impacto do treinamento de
resistência pesada na força muscular e
na composição corporal de adultos mais
velhos acima de 70. Os pesquisadores
queriam entender se esse tipo de treino
poderia manter a massa muscular e a
força ao longo do tempo em comparação
com o treino de intensidade moderada ou
ausência de exercício. Então eles
compararam sem exercício, moderado, que
é geralmente o idoso quer fazer, e o
intenso. Então a idade era entre 64 e 75
anos de idade. São três grupos, como eu
falei, um que praticava exercícios
pesados
de força, né, de resistência, outro com
treino moderado e o grupo controle que
não fazia nada. Então o foco principal
era a força dos músculos extensores das
pernas,
medida de várias formas, além da
composição corporal, massa magra e
gordura visceral.
Então, o estudo envolveu 369 idosos que
não tinham problemas de saúde aparentes.
Eram 61% de mulheres, 39% de homens.
E o que torna esse estudo especial é o
acompanhamento a longo prazo que
observou os participantes por 4 anos
após o início da intervenção. Ou seja,
mesmo que tenha sido só um ano de
atividade, o a observação foi por 4 anos
e isso permitiu uma análise sólida dos
resultados a longo prazo. Então, durante
o período de treinamento, o grupo de
resistência pesada realizou exercícios
de academias privadas, enquanto o grupo
de intensidade moderada praticou em casa
e em hospitais. Então, ambos os grupos
seguiram programas supervisionados,
uma progressão prédeterminada, enquanto
o grupo controle permaneceu sedentário.
Então, resultados,
os mais importantes resultados. Após os
4 anos de observação,
o grupo que praticou exercício de
resistência pesada conseguiu manter a
força isométrica das pernas, enquanto o
grupo de treino moderado e o grupo de
controle perderam força. Olha só isso
aqui, gente. O grupo de treino moderado
teve um resultado muito parecido com o
grupo controle. Olha só, a massa magra
também foi mantida no grupo de
resistência pesada, enquanto diminuiu
nos outros dois grupos.
Então isso aqui me chamou muita atenção,
tá? Essa história de fazer isso moderado
em idoso não é uma boa não.
Então esse resultado são significativos
que mostram que um ano de treinamento
pesado pode ter efeitos duradouros na
manutenção da força e da massa muscular.
E curiosamente os níveis de gordura
visceral
permaneceram estáveis tanto no grupo de
resistência pesada quanto no de
intensidade moderada, mas aumentaram em
8% do grupo controle. Então aqui nesse
ponto valeu a pena fazer o moderado, né?
Porque aí não acumulou mais gordura
visceral enquanto que os sedentários
acumularam.
Então você sabe, como eu já falei várias
vezes, que manter a força muscular em
doses é crucial, pois isso tá
diretamente ligado à mobilidade também,
agilidade, independência e qualidade de
vida. Então, esse estudo fornece
evidências claras de que o treinamento
de resistência pesada deve ser parte do
plano de exercício de qualquer pessoa
que queira envelhecer com saúde. Apenas
um ano de treino intenso, ou seja, foram
4 anos de observação, mas só foi um ano
de treino intenso. Pode gerar benefícios
que duram por anos. Isso é fundamental
para preservar capacidade funcional e
prevenir quedas e outras complicações
associadas ao envelhecimento.
Os pesquisadores acreditam que o sucesso
do treinamento pesado está ligado à
adaptações neuromusculares.
Mesmo quando a massa muscular diminui de
forma ligeira, né, ou leve, o corpo
consegue manter a força graças a uma
melhor função neuromuscular.
Isso inclui maior recrutamento
de unidades motoras e o aprimoramento
das conexões entre os nervos e os
músculos, resultando uma performance
muscular melhorada.
Então, comparando esse estudo com outros
anteriores,
isso aí faz o quê?
mais evidências,
aumentando o corpo de pesquisa que
confirma os benefícios do treinamento de
resistência em adultos mais velhos.
Estudos anteriores já tinham demonstrado
que treinos de conta duração podem
melhorar a força muscular, mas poucas
pesquisas haviam acompanhado os efeitos
a longo prazo, 4 anos, né? Como foi esse
estudo que eu falei para vocês aqui?
Eu, se eu fosse velhinho, não teria
feito só um ano, não. Faria os 4 anos aí
do período de observação, né?
O que o estudo destaca é que o
treinamento de resistência pesada é mais
eficaz do que o treino moderado para
manter a força ao longo do tempo. Isso é
meu óbvio, mas aqui me chamou muita
atenção o fato de o pessoal que fez esse
de força moderada não ter tido umas
melhoras. e alguns critérios.
E óbvio que você sabe que esses
benefícios do treino de resistência não
só é exclusivo pros idosos, né? Precisa
com adultos mais jovens mostrar
resultados semelhantes com treinos
intensos proporcionando maiores
benefícios a longo prazo. Beleza? Então,
se você tá acima dos 60 anos ou conhece
alguém que tá próximo
acima dos 60, pede para ele virar
marumbeiro. Certo?
Aqui ele não tá especificando com tanta
clareza o que que é treino pesado, tá?
Às vezes o que eu acho que é treino
pesado para ele é é é
treino ultra pesado. Não sei, né?
Isso é muito importante, pessoal. A
musculação é muito importante. Tem uma
pergunta sem responder. Vamos lá.
Ué, para mim não tem não. Eu respondi
todas.
Só se for é ao vivo que você tá falando
ou do documento.
Documento eu já cobri o documento todo
ao vivo. Tá bom. Mas eu não vi não.
Cadê?
Não, o do Stradió eu já respondi. Qual
foi a pergunta que eu não respondi?
Não, eu respondi tudo.
Ó, aquela história do logol da vitamina
C, eu já respondi.
O estradiol melhor absolvido da noite,
eu já respondi.
Antes do estradiol,
não,
da tatuagem eu respondi.
Eu perguntava no documento.
Você não tá se confundindo não, Maria
Helena.
Qual que é a pergunta? Eu não tô achando
essa pergunta.
É de tatuagem. Respondi.
É pergunta é tua.
Não apareceu para mim.
É longa, então. Mas é, então foi algum
problema aí, ó. Quando você escreve um
texto muito longo aqui no
chat ao vivo dá da BO, entendeu? Deve
ter sido isso, tá bom? Então, a gente
pode estar respondendo essa sua dúvida
na próxima live, tá? Eu vou encerrar
então, pessoal. Obrigado por ter
assistido essa live. Espero que semana
que vem o Streamyard esteja funcionando
corretamente.
Até a próxima. Um beijo no coração de
vocês.